i'm okay spending money on a staycation
i'm just
sick of spending money on larissa's
surgeries
[Music]
my goal is to change my boobs again
to get bigger the fact that she just got
her boobs done wants to get them done
again
to me it's not
economical etiquette does not have
patience to deal with the women's stuff
and he believes is just go to the gym
gonna change your butt
my casey i need the surgery and he does
not understand those things
the recovery process of a surgery is
in in its intensive care it's non-stop
morning to night assistance
to have a big killer yes let me get you
an antibiotic here in about five minutes
with the pain killer okay
and that is something that i am not up
to do again
[Music]
i feel like i just got off a
merry-go-round right
can you imagine every time that you
started to talk
imagine every time you start to talk you
hear about surgeries
i feel like i'm in the biggest total war
match
ever and i'm not even playing you the
ones take care of
me my surgeon no i do not i already did
that
and practically broke my back over the
period of time bending and twisting and
lifting out of bed
sitting down on the toilet not one of
your friends we're here to even check on
you
yeah don't come on out with your mother
everything behaving to you
you're gonna be having problems she's
like don't know
all right let's take that fork in the
road right now
and we can find our way away from one
[Music]
another